this is also the year that brought these
top guns together again tom cruise and
val kilmer the sequel finally hits
theaters tomorrow tomorrow and yep that
means the long-awaited reunion between
iceman and maverick
this is your captain speaking let's get
to work
you know there were so many beautiful
moments but i think the most beautiful
were the scenes with you and val i felt
that way just looking at each other and
you see that scene it's very special i
am
dangerous know the first one i really
rallied hard for him to make the movie i
was like you val you got to make this
movie you know you just was like it's
gonna be it would be amazing you figured
it out yet who's the best pilot val's
triumphant top gun return comes seven
years after his voice was tragically
destroyed due to throat cancer i didn't
have any scenes with him but i did get
to meet him i think his scene is really
moving and beautiful for the real fans
of the original movie there's so much
there that you know that they'll enjoy
all these references and throwbacks to
the original let's go
you could tell he was so excited to be
back among these people you could tell
the feeling of of that nostalgic reunion
energy whose side are you on how are you
doing
i'm
even though talking can be a challenge
val's outlook couldn't have been more
optimistic when we last sat down with
him entertainment tonight was on the set
of top gun back in 1985.
do you really have to work
damn it
so we want to show you something okay
[Music]
my father was in the air force i was
excited to be able to get to see an
aspect of the navy that civilians can't
see
i
[Music]
years
remember
[Music]
you